quelle longueur son entreprise compte
120 salariés
il s'agit bien d'une pme mais ce
directeur voudrait bien grandir tout
simplement parce que le marché le
sollicitent de plus en plus ces petites
bagues une des spécialités de
l'entreprise sont devenus indispensables
dans l'aéronautique
ça c'est une vague de masse c'est un
élément qui va surtout les avions peut
demander qu'on fabrique ce ses
composants point nos clients importants
acteurs importants de l'aéronautique
pour produire plus et assurer de
nouveaux marchés il faut réorganiser
l'entreprise bien et c'est là
qu'intervient la bpi la banque publique
d'investissement ici les contacts sont
engagées depuis plusieurs mois
un parrainage qui a déjà fait ses
preuves on doit être à peu près 1 500
entreprises avec lesquelles on qu'on
embarque dans ces parcours de 24 mois on
a pu constater pendant les deux ans du
programme la croissance de leur chiffre
d'affaires était de + 29 % t-il
d'affaires et la croissance de leurs
effectifs + 36% entre lui et j'en
rajoutais un tiers aujourd'hui 13 pme de
bourgogne et de franche comté étaient
rassemblées toutes en forte croissance
et donc appelés à devenir des hôtes et y
des entreprises de taille intermédiaire
de plus de 250 salariés
pour ce chef d'entreprise jurassien il y
a urgence on est trop petit parce qu'on
est dans les grands donneurs d'ordre et
des sociétés comme airbus comme psa
comme renault des grandes sociétés et le
problème d'être dans ces grandes
sociétés d'être petit bain jours ils
vont nous dire on peut plus travailler
avec vous donc il faut absolument pour
on connaît de la croissance et pour être
plus présent chez eux quand elle crée un
emploi
il y en a 3 il ya 3,5 autre emploi qui
se développe dans le territoire puisque
l'entreprise de taille intermédiaire
elle va faire travailler d'autres
entreprises
les futurs locomotives économiques sont
majoritairement issus de l'industrie
mais on en trouve aussi dans les
services et l'agriculture